let's see if we can quickly talk to to
one more person here let's go to our
caller from the 8th 1/8 area code caller
from 8 1 8 go ahead
hi David this is Chris from Los Angeles
I've called him said before I'm a member
I think you've mentioned before both the
Institute for securing democracy and I
think bought Sentinel as organizations
that identify and track Russian troll
bot operations and in being on Twitter
and in battling these these trolls scum
myself
founded they used an npc icon and just
curious what was my question what do you
think US citizens to do to combat the
disinformation and lies propaganda
spread by these Russian troll BOTS yeah
so first and foremost you've got to
critically analyze primary sources of
news so anytime you are seeing a hashtag
movement dogpiling on Twitter linking
them to a particular article you always
on any issue you're trying to understand
you've got to go to the primary sources
that are reporting it and critically
analyze those for yourself as far as the
micro of dealing with BOTS and trolls on
social media I just mute them I don't
actually know you know at the policy
level I don't know what should be done
and I don't know what could be done but
at the individual level if you've got
NPC which by the way we'll talk about
later on today's show I'm going to talk
about the NPC meme non playable
character if you've got NPC and your
user name on Twitter I'm immediately
muting you if you call me an NPC I am
immediately muting you and it's not
about creating an echo chamber it's just
about getting any non serious actors out
of the way right I follow a bunch of
different right-wing voices on Twitter
it's not that I don't want to hear from
writers it's just you've got to get
right the deliberate disinformation out
of your ecosystem yeah it seems that
those armies of these types of users on
Twitter right now that are just
spreading disinformation as much as
possible and I just as a US citizen and
someone who cares about our elections
I want to combat this this issue
and take it on head-on and I just
wondering what we can do as a collective
body yeah you know I'm sure Trump and
his administration is not gonna go after
the Russian trow BOTS he's not doing
that you didn't have a cyber army ready
to deploy but I'm just curious what you
know what your thoughts are and I'm glad
you thought you bring up the issue and
please talk about it more I will
continue to this is a top issue right
now yeah absolutely thank you so much
for the call we will take a quick break
sorry to everybody we didn't get to 20
people holding geez but not today
I apologize we will take calls again
next week audience questions after the
break